vous souvenez vous de ce que vous
faisiez il y a six semaines j'en suis
sûr il y a six semaines nous étions le
17 mars le jour du déclenchement du
confinement depuis cette date
vous avez changé vous n'êtes plus tout à
fait les mêmes vous avez changé alors
par la manière the mask non par six
semaines parfois un peu moins vous avez
entièrement renouvelée l'enveloppent qui
recouvre votre corps la peau est
l'organe le plus important du corps
humain de mètres carrés elle est
constituée de trois couches l'hypoderme
le derme et l'épiderme
c'est l'épiderme qui se renouvelle il
est constitué de cellules qui se forme à
sa base les cellules se divisent et
repousse celle qui se trouve au dessus
chaque fois qu'une nouvelle cellule
apparaît les plus anciennes remontent
d'un cran et quand elles arrivent en
surface elmer et forment la couche
cornée d'hôtel finissent par se séparer
d'après les spécialistes un adulte
perdrait et fabriquerait en moyenne 35
kg de pop art
pas étonnant qu'on se sente aussi bien
dedans c'est un éternel renouvellement
comme les capsules 2d confiné
si vous avez aimé cette capsule
n'hésitez pas à laisser un coup ce bleu
vous pouvez également voir ou revoir les
précédentes en cliquant sur le côté
gauche jean publie une nouvelle chaque
jour alors pour être sûr de ne louper
aucune et bien abonnez vous et activer
la petite cloche
et n'oubliez surtout pas nous sommes
toujours confiné mais on reste en rien